you've probably seen this and it's wild at
366 feet tall it's officially the largest
fear and the largest screen in the
world it's so massive that it took a
crane to assemble the Crane That Could
assemble the Dome the shell is a 580
000 square foot fully programmable LED screen
named the exosphere and believe it or not the
whole thing can run on a single MacBook Air it's
designed to give you the most immersive experience
with an infrasound haptic flooring system that
carries base through the floors and a beam form
sound system embedded in the walls that delivers
sound directly to each seat and I think it could
completely transform live entertainment but at
the price tag of 2.3 billion dollars it's a big
gamble so the MSG sphere is it a pioneering
breakthrough or a massive waste of money
a portion of this video sponsored by betterhelp
I think there's something about a sphere that's
captivated the human imagination for ages the
ancient Greek saw the sphere as an embodiment
of Harmony and Perfection boulay saw the sphere
as the sublime tribute to the infinite Cosmos a
symbol of the universe Buckminster Fuller saw
the sphere as the epitome of efficiency and
strength and now we unveil the sphere the
perfect encapsulation of the 21st century
Zeitgeist what's unique about the sphere is
that the form and the experience are one there
are other spherical venues around the world but
this is the first one to capitalize on its form
and that's because the sphere is actually one of
the worst shapes for Acoustics because the sound
it bounces around the hall and it gets muddled
so when you go inside spherical venues there's
still the traditional curved boxes which is
the ideal shape for Acoustics so when they
were building the sphere they developed a new
sound system that uses audio beams to deliver
sound directly to individual scenes there's
168 000 speakers which means at roughly 20
000 seats there's about 8.4 speakers per person
essentially the whole Space is a speaker this
allows them to capitalize on the spherical form
to create a completely new genre of entertainment
that's kind of a mix of a planetarium IMAX
Opera Hall and stadium and VR goggles and it
also includes haptic technology for cooling
winds rumbling seats and even scents to
people into the show there's no columns
or structural obstructions and because
your viewing experience is not only towards the
stage but it's 360. every seat in the venue will
get a unique highly stimulating experience well
except these 800 seats somebody's getting fired
U2 is going to be the opening act of the sphere
and there's a reason for that according to
Rolling Stone the band is a natural fit for the
sphere because they're constantly experimenting
and trying to push the boundaries in live music
experience the problem is not everyone is you too
and actually there's quite a lot of limitations
on who can perform there given the unique form
standard visuals are going to be very distorted
on the interior and the haptic technology that
adds another layer of complexity there's a mini
version of the sphere that allows artists to
test their ideas before the show but even with
that the amount of effort and time required is
considerably higher than what they're used to I
mean what kind of camera can even create videos
for a gigantic 360 screen oh well there's one the
MSG Studio they developed a camera that's the most
capable of producing videos for the interior
screen so they kind of have a monopoly on this
even for you too they said the time and expense is
required to develop the visual pieces it made it
really hard for them to be spontaneous for their
act this could turn off a lot of artists because
based on the time and cost of developing a show
for this venue well first of all they'd have to
sell out the show and it might not be practical
to develop a whole show that can only be played
at this one venue a lot of artists actually feel
like the flashy visuals would overpower the music
and when they were trying to secure the act for
the show a lot of artists just straight up said no
the exterior has a similar problem yes it's going
to be a whole new genre of advertising that's
creative and different but right now there's not
a lot of companies who know how to Market on a
spherical screen which could be an issue because
it costs 2.3 billion dollars it could take them
um a long time to make that back and in
fact MSG and James Dolan the brainchild
and the primary investor behind the sphere
is currently facing lawsuits from several
construction companies for more than
three million dollars of unpaid bills
plus according to SMP Global the sphere is
going to take up about 95 000 megawatt hour
of electricity annually at the rate of 18 cents
per kilowatt hour in Vegas that's roughly 17.2
million dollars a year and just for reference
a typical commercial building of between 15
000 to 25 000 square feet consumes about
180 megawatt hour so the sphere consumes
the energy of roughly 529 of these buildings
and with the money they've already sunk into
the project and the money that they will be paying
the audience might be the ones paying the price
I absolutely love what I do but it has really
Amplified this weird relationship that I've
always had with making mistakes I'd always get
into this Loop of constantly overthinking and
being myself up for making the smallest mistakes
to a point where I was getting exhausting and
unproductive and it's been really helpful to work
with therapists on recognizing some of my thought
patterns and just trying to make some small
improvements which is why I'm really excited
to tell you about today's sponsor betterhelp
makes therapy accessible and affordable and
it's a hundred percent online so it's really
easy to adapt it to your schedule finding a
therapist can be really hard especially if
you're limited to the ones in your area so
if you're finding that your therapist is
not a good fit you can easily switch to
a new therapist for free so if you follow
the link betterhelp.com damily you get 10
and off your first month so you can try and see if
it helps thank you better Hull for sponsoring this
video so what I was saying is they've already
spent a lot of money on this project but there
are those exceptional projects that despite their
costs or public pushbacks or the amount of time it
took to build have been incredibly successful and
they've even become icons of their cities they've
transcended the mere function of a building and
they've become destinations that people travel to
and this fear it could be one of those buildings
it's been shared millions of times and it's kind
of out of this world and at its core it's a very
Democratic idea there's a connection between the
inside and the outside that allows the indoor
Ticket concert to be projected outside for the
non-paying audience to scene this connection
has never been done before in a traditional
music venue because they typically require a very
controlled Lighting and Sound Edition and so it is
a first of its kind and it has the opportunity
to create some really incredible public spaces
or viewing platforms but based on what we're
seeing right now any walking space or public
space around it is a little underwhelming to the
north we have this massive Golf Club to the east
we have a bunch of Office Buildings and to itself
we have a Holiday Inn who will get these fabulous
views it's right along the Vegas Monorail line
so at least you can see it while you're moving
down the strip right now it seems like most of the
sphere's exterior space will likely be dedicated
to parking to meet the minimum of 13 900 spots and
honestly based on the skill of this thing I don't
even know what it's gonna be like to stay up close
but the renderings do show a ring at the base
so maybe that's in the works if it does remain
mostly parking lots maybe it could at least become
a drive-in movie theater although the sphere
is a totally private project and technically
they don't have a lot of responsibilities
to improve the public realm for a massive
project like this there's always opportunities
to create an amazing public sphere take this
in Vegas alone there's tons of examples of public
viewing spaces that's created by privately owned
buildings but maybe the best way we can compare
will be to look at the exact same building just
in a different context the MSG sphere in
Stratford and East London it's planned on
a 4.7 acre triangular site that's been sitting
empty for six years and the key difference from
Vegas is this Podium surrounding the sphere and
the variety of public spaces that's programmed
in from the start there's the viewing space
there's the Serene Garden space there's the
community space and these different levels create
a very Dynamic public space and there's not one
not two but four pedestrian access points that
connected to the surrounding Bridges so that means
you can come here and even if you're not seeing
a show you can come and hang out and just watch
whatever's on the screen and they've actually
designed in a place for the audience to gather
outside but despite how well it's been
integrated with the site 850 out of the
1200 resident groups voted against the project
who understandably said they don't want to be
forced to live face to face with an enormous
glowing advertising ball the project is on a
temporary hole to address some of these concerns
but there are some big Arguments for the project
it's going to create thousands of jobs and it's
going to bring in roughly 60 000 people daily
for 300 days of the year to this part of the
city very sound argument and so if this thing
passes and if they're able to figure out a way
to integrate this obnoxious object into an urban
environment that's gonna set a new precedence for
what's acceptable when it comes to advertising
disguised as entertainment or for light pollution
in residential areas and as we have so often seen
we don't necessarily really know the impact
of these things until it's a little too late
foreign
this was created using oils lights colors
and alcohol smashed between two plates you
place them on a projector placed throughout
the concert venue and you sink the plates to
the Beat of the Music even this primitive
technology saw a mass adoption when it was
developed in the 60s and it transformed live
performances from a listening experience to
a visual experience look at how far we've
come we're entering yet another era where
music and art is a multi-sensory experience
that transcend any other concert or Movie
experience it could open the doors to a
completely new expression of creativity
first Vegas now London this thing is ripe
for replication and as Trends spread like
wildfire these days we could be seeing
more and more of these giant eyeballs all
over the world but for all its promise the
sphere also poses some fundamental concerns
and it's especially when things are so
shiny and new that we need to be extra
diligent because things that seem like progress
sometimes have a weird way of setting us back
thanks for watching guys what do
you think about this fear let me
know in the comments I also have a
Discord server and a newsletter I'll
leave the links below and with that
I'll see you guys in the next video